NOW IT IS TIME TO PLAY WEDDED
MISS.
WEDDED MISS.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
WHEN A MAN AND WOMAN LOVE EACH
OTHER VERY MUCH, THEY SOMETIMES
GET MARRIED IN SOME REALLY
ILL-ADVISED THEMED WEDDINGS, AND
THEN THESE PHOTOS LIVE FOREVER
ON PINTEREST.
(LAUGHTER)
UH, LIKE THIS FLOWER GIRL
DRESSED AS A DALEK FROM A DOCTOR
WHO -THEMED WEDDING, WHICH...
(LAUGHTER)
...I ACTUALLY THINK IS SUPER
ADORBS, BY THE WAY.
SHE'S GOT THE LITTLE WHISKER!
UH, THIS IS PERFECT, BECAUSE,
LIKE A DALEK, TODDLERS FEEL NO
COMPASSION OR REMORSE. UM...
(LAUGHTER)
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA READ
YOU TWO WEDDING THEMES, AND FOR
250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO GUESS
WHICH ONE IS REAL AND WHICH ONE
WE JUST MADE UP, ALL RIGHT?
FIRST ONE, A WEDDING AT THE
CHEERS BAR WITH EVERYONE DRESSED
UP AS CHARACTERS OR...
A KLINGON WEDDING?
DOUG.
>> UH... (LAUGHS)
AS MUCH AS I'D HAVE LOVED TO
ATTEND EITHER...
(LAUGHTER)
...I'M GONNA GO WITH KLINGON
WEDDING.
>> HARDWICK: LET'S FIND OUT.
KLINGON!
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
>> WE'RE TOO UGLY TO GET
MARRIED, SO LET'S MAKE OURSELVES
UGLIER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WE'LL BE PRETEND UGLY AND
REAL UGLY.
>> HARDWICK: UH, LITTLE KNOWN
FACT-- KLINGON WEDDINGS ARE
INCREDIBLY POPULAR. UH...
>> OH, MY GOD, I CANNOT BELIEVE
THOSE PEOPLE HAVE FOUND TRUE
LOVE.
>> BUT IS IT... INSTEAD OF,
LIKE, BREAKING A GLASS, DO THEY
JUST, LIKE, KILL A BABY AND
DRINK ITS BLOOD?
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
YEAH. MM-HMM.
>> IT'S, LIKE, YOU CAN ONLY GET
HOTTER FROM HERE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> MOST COUPLES WANT TO HAVE THE
SAME FOREHEAD.
(LAUGHTER)
>> IT'S A PERSONAL CHOICE, DOUG,
IT'S A PERSONAL CHOICE.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE.
A FREAK SHOW WEDDING WITH THE
BRIDE AND GROOM HANGING FROM
HOOKS, OR... A FAULT IN OUR
STARS WEDDING WITH THE BRIDE AND
GROOM WEARING OXYGEN
TANKS? MEGAN.
>> THE FREAK SHOW WEDDING, COME
ON.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, LET'S
FIND OUT.
THE FREAK SHOW WEDDING!
>> WHOA, OH, MY GOD, THEY'RE
FLOATING.
>> I JUST LIKE THAT SHE'S
WEARING THE TRADITIONAL HOT
GREEN.
>> SO THE VOWS WERE, "OW."
>> HARDWICK: OW.
>> "DO YOU TAKE THIS... OW."
>> HARDWICK: BONUS POINTS, NAME
SOMETHING ON THEIR REGISTRY.
MEGAN.
>> UH, NEOSPORIN?
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, SURE.
>> OW.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, POINTS, YEAH.
PROBABLY.
DOUG.
>> UH, THEY PUT, UH, STOOLS ON
THEIR REGISTRY SO THEY COULD GET
DOWN.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> OH, I HOPE SOMEBODY GETS
THOSE.
>> HARDWICK: DOUG.
>> UH, THEY FOUND EACH OTHER
'CAUSE THEY'RE BOTH SWINGERS.
>> HARDWICK: HEY, POINTS.
NEXT ONE, STAR WARS WEDDING WITH
ADMIRAL ACKBAR BEING MARRIED BY
THE OFFICIANT SLAVE LEIA...
(BELL DINGS)
OR...
>> I'M READY.
>> HARDWICK: SAVED BY THE BELL
WEDDING WITH THE COUPLE BEING
MARRIED BY THE ACTUAL DUSTIN
DIAMOND.
KURT.
>> GOD DAMN IT, STAR WARS
WEDDING.
>> HARDWICK: LET'S FIND OUT.
YES, STAR WARS WEDDING.
BUT, WAIT...
>> HE'S-HE'S SO EXCITED.
>> HARDWICK: WAIT... BUT...
WHEN ADMIRAL... RIGHT BEFORE HE
PUTS THE RINGS ON HIM, HE GOES,
"IT'S A TRAP!"
AND THEN NO WEDDING.
>> IT'S A TRAP!
>> HARDWICK: IT'S A TRAP!
>> HE'S IN THE MIDDLE OF SAYING
IT: "IT'S A TRAP!"
>> HARDWICK: IT'S A TRAP!
IT'S A TRAP!
>> IT'S A TRAP!
HE COULDN'T... THEY COULDN'T
JUST GET ORANGE PAINT FOR HIS
HANDS-- HE HAD TO HAVE GLOVES.
>> HARDWICK: GLOVES.
>> GET YOUR SHIT TOGETHER, STAR
WARS WEIRDOS.
>> HARDWICK: I... NO.
MY HANDS WERE TERRIBLY BURNED--
IT WAS A TRAP.
(GRUNTS)
>> HE CAN'T WAIT TO SLITHER HIS
JABBA THE HUT UP INSIDE HER
SAND...
>> HARDWICK: 100 POINTS TO KURT.
UH...
COMEDIANS, WHY DOES THIS COUPLE
END UP GETTING DIVORCED?
KURT.
>> OH, UM, YOU KNOW, THEY JUST
GREW APART, IT'S ACTUALLY KIND
OF A SAD STORY, I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD JOKE ABOUT IT, BUT HE DID
HAVE A REALLY TINY LIGHTSABER!
GOD DAMN IT, YOU MADE ME JOKE
ABOUT IT.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS, OH,
OKAY, POINTS.
MEGAN.
>> WELL...
LIKE, NOT TO GET TOO SERIOUS,
BUT, LIKE, HE IS MON CALAMARI
AND SHE'S PRESBYTERIAN, AND THEY
JUST HAVE...
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT CORE VALUES.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> NOT THE SAME.
>> HARDWICK: DOUG.
>> THEIR FIRST MISTAKE WAS
HONEYMOONING IN THE SARLACC PIT.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, YEAH.
THAT WAS A TERRIBLE IDEA.
YEAH.
UH, THEY WERE MARRIED FOR A
WHILE WHEN THEY SPLIT UP, BUT
NOW THAT GUY IS SOLO.
ALL RIGHT, UM...
NEXT ONE.
A BEAUTY AND THE BEAST WEDDING
WITH THE GROOM IN FULL BEAST
MAKEUP...
(BELL DINGS)
OR PULP FICTION WEDDING WITH THE
BEST MAN DRESSED AS THE GIMP.
DOUG.
>> (LAUGHS)
THIS TIME THERE'S ONLY ONE THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO BE AT.
AND THAT WOULD BE THE BEAUTY AND
THE BEAST WEDDING.
>> HARDWICK: LET US FIND OUT.
>> SOUNDS BEAUTIFUL.
>> HARDWICK: YES, OF COURSE.
FOR BONUS POINTS, PLEASE GIVE ME
A TOAST AS THE BEST MAN.
KURT.
>> UH, BEAUTY AND THE BEAST?
MORE LIKE BOOTY AND THOSE TEATS,
YOU SEE... I'M DRUNK, I'M SORRY.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
MEGAN.
>> IT'S A GOOD THING STACY LIKES
DOGGY STYLE, 'CAUSE THAT'S THE
ONLY WAY I DO IT.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
>> 'CAUSE I... 'CAUSE I'M REAL
HORNY.
>> HARDWICK: DOUG.
>> TALE AS OLD AS TIME.
SONG AS OLD AS RHYME.
BEAUTY AND THE BEAST.
>> HARDWICK: WHAT A COP-OUT.
>> THAT'S A VERY...
>> THE PERFECT TOAST FOR THE
OCCASION.
>> HARDWICK: A LITTLE TOO
PERFECT.
ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
LAST ONE, A KNIGHT RIDER WEDDING
WHERE THE COUPLE IS MARRIED BY
KITT OR A GHOSTBUSTERS WEDDING
WHERE THE GROOMSMEN AIN'T AFRAID
OF NO GHOSTS.
KURT BRAUNOHLER.
>> GHOSTBUSTERS WEDDING.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, PROBABLY.
LET'S FIND OUT.
YES, OF COURSE.
WHEN WAS DAVID SPADE A
GHOSTBUSTER?
>> HE CAN'T WAIT TO GET HIS
STREAM SLIMED.
FOR BONUS POINTS, WHAT WOULD THE
THEME OF YOUR DREAM WEDDING BE,
KURT?
>> OH, UH, OH, IT WOULD BE, UH,
UH, TICKLE ME FELCHMO.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT-- IT'S A
REAL COMMON WEDDING.
>> HARDWICK: UH, MEGAN.
>> I WOULD-I WOULD MARRY A
RESCUE PUPPY.
I WOULD.
>> MEGAN, WHAT'S YOUR DREAM
WEDDING?
"OH, SOMETHING SAD AND NOT
ALLOWED BY LAW."
>> THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.